[Music]
Jason Aldean the Academy of Country
Music's reigning Entertainer of the Year
is back in Las Vegas this weekend hoping
to take home the honor for the 3rd
straight year what's it like for you to
be back here man you know I think
everybody's sort of tried to make this
you know this thing about me coming back
to Vegas kind of tried to make it a
little bigger than it was for me that
you know I've got a million great
memories in Vegas you know and one
horrible one it's been just over six
months since all Dean's performance at a
music festival was tragically cut short
when a gunman opened fire on the crowd
from the 32nd floor of the Mandalay Bay
Hotel well I love this town I mean I
love Las Vegas I love the city and you
know was looking forward to coming back
out here and and and I think this is the
right setting for me you know to be out
here with the country music family you
know my friends and people in the
country music world the shooting last
October was the country's deadliest mass
shooting 58 people were killed and
hundreds injured all Dean invited some
of those survivors to watch his
rehearsal Friday afternoon what were you
thinking about as you were performing
for them I think more than anything just
kind of glad to see him here I just
think we're everybody that was there you
know we're all kind of forever bonded
man so it's always cool to see those
people and sort of catch up because you
know people don't get it unless they're
you know they were actually there and so
I think it's therapeutic for everybody
just to sort of talk about it a little
bit the healing process began less than
a week after the shooting when all Dean
performed the Tom Petty song I won't
back down on Saturday Night Live
did you realize how cathartic that would
be for the whole country you know I
think we knew that us you know
performing on that show and if we did it
the right way would be a you know a big
thing for everybody I felt like that was
sort of a you know not only a healing
moment for me but it was also a chance
for me to sort of tell everybody else
like you know this is horrible and it's
you know but it's it's it's okay to
start the healing process and start to
pick up the pieces and move on
over the past 13 years Jason Aldean has
become one of country music's biggest
stars selling more than 10 million
albums his eighth rearview town was
released on Friday that album was
recorded before the horrific events here
but the title track is really
interesting it's about looking forward
and not looking back to be honest pretty
much the whole album was done maybe
other than four songs or something by
the time the shooting happened but for
me it's about you know putting things
that have sort of held you down you know
things have been a black cloud hanging
over you sort of putting that in the
past and looking down the road to some
better days for CBS this morning
Saturday vladimir duthiers las vegas